you're gonna know I have a background  for I think the first 17 years of my  life I chose comedy but dance shows me  if anything dance has been running from  him for years  okay he keep chasing dance and dances  lying no no I'm not for your little leg  make sure we do it like we practiced  in fact Tiffany she doesn't have real  feet yeah this just flat that's flat  fake feet yeah she's not a good dancer  Tiffany is the better dancer by far one  thing that I have that nobody else  really has is natural rhythm  Kevin you know he think he's an expert  on everything thank you  I'm out he says I gotta see it once I'm  good to go  and of course like you know he saw it  like eight times he was like oh all  right that's the thing okay  oh they I know what I know I came in and  watched and support it I nailed it in  two minutes  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]